Now let's take a step back and see what you have learned so far.
And the way we're going to organize this is
that we're going to draw pictures of so-called complexity classes.
And a complexity class is basically a collection of problems
that can be solved under given constraints or resources.
So you take a bunch of problems,
you introduce a constraint
such as the one we have seen with NP
where we said must be solvable in non-deterministic polynomial time,
and then you sort problems.
Some problems will fall into the complexity class,
other problems will basically just fall outside of the complexity class.
And of course you already know some complexity classes very well.
So let's do a little warm-up quiz here.
So you already know the class P from the previous units.
And I just want you to quickly fill in if the complexity class P
is the class of all problems that can be solved in
polynomial or exponential time
on a deterministic or non-deterministic RAM.